everyone welcome to another exciting
episode the instant trim interview show
I'm Jimmy I'm Roy and today we were
reviewing edge of tomorrow starring Tom
Cruise and Emily Blunt yes and directed
by Doug Liman who directed go the Bourne
Identity
mr. and mrs. Smith
all sorts of movies jumper anyway so you
know what it's an interesting enough
trailer if you were like Groundhog's Day
means oblivion meets Jake Gyllenhaal
source code sure I like that move that's
good so anyway Tom Cruise finally look a
little old so that might be makeup the
next movie he's gonna look a little
younger but don't know this is a sci-fi
movie this is kind of the first evidence
we see a bit but it looks like they're
doing warm and analog comes Saifullah
those look like actual like cargo
carriers and there's a texture yeah
these are actually real suits they made
these suits for really yeah and it shows
you just when he's running in it it
looks ridiculous yeah now one thing that
I read is that they actually trained for
months to learn how to be able just to
be able to physically carry themselves
in these suits the suits weigh about 80
pounds jeans so it's a little bit hectic
to to be wearing all that oh the other
thing that I was reading about is like
in between takes they also have ribs
away off of their shoulders Wow
literally so they weren't just getting
clicky oh that makes sense so now
there's bill paxton love bill paxton
Jamie and Bill backs and we go way back
Jimmy wants met bill paxton at a social
event and said to him in that quote I've
seen all of your movies now if any of
you know Bill Paxton
he's started over three thousand movies
Jimmy's seen every single one that the
person most surprised to hear this I'm
still packed sweep cell so this is
something to consider but Bill Paxton
will store that will throw that photo is
handsome gets is a great she's a great
general mustache and gives with the
stunner
I think the Bourne films are great he
only made one well I think bored
identity is really strong I think it's
good to this is also really good it's a
jumper not this one yeah you know what
we all make mistakes so this is him and
he's out of these battle sequences look
they do I do it to me it's like if
Normandy Beach was staged in the future
instead of the French or fighting aliens
that yeah
I appreciate you guys yeah I was gonna
say something snooty but it's exactly
what I thought so we're in sync here and
then we're about to sample a blossom so
they revealed this kind of aspect of the
story which is they both have this kind
of repeat thing every time they die in
this battle they wake up again and
relive the same thing and then they
realize they're together
so then they start meeting up every day
now the hashtag for this movie and also
I think the tagline for this movie
arrestee live directly live die repeat
exactly do you think no these things
that they're starting to push push it a
little bit with how young Tom Cruise's
love interests can be I do think that
there is some there stretching that a
little bit now one thing I brought up
with Jay s earlier is that the scope of
the film is going to be crucial in order
for me to enjoy it
source-code really only took place over
about 30 seconds of time so every time
you repeated it you had like a chance to
sort of dig it's taking place over
more than that it was like it's like a
it's like three minutes or something
it's a very short amount of time yeah
when he gets into the there's an exact
number I think it's seven minutes okay
so but still a very good time enough
where you can actually have it play out
in real time multiple times oh yes yes
and each time you can sort of get into
some other intricacies of the details
yeah so with this if it is this huge
like who knows how long it is if it's a
day if it's a few hours right I just
want things I love the source code it's
how you could get deeper into the story
and we're gonna peel back the layers
every time it repeats something out but
they could do something simple this
looks a little more like Groundhog Day
like a full day yeah
but yeah I mean this Doug Liman is good
at shooting like very very slick actions
and this looks like a very slight yeah
absolutely
it's got like a just to read outlook put
it about oh so it's about as slick as
you can make Brit
yeah that's exactly right that's exactly
right
but it's cool because they as you get
further further into this trailer you
realize it's there's aliens you know
there's some really insane aliens yeah
well she'll and it looks like JJ Abrams
may have had something to do it is like
the squid monster from matrix yeah
that's real bond there you go
we're still living in the shadow of the
matrix but I think I mean this looks
very much like oblivion and from an
aesthetics yeah I know and so the
million dollar question is well Tom
Cruise died at the end of this movie in
order to save Emily blank or get her out
of her timeline is that the question so
like it hasn't been now no no I know
that that's a loaded question because
first of all you already know in the
trailer he's gonna die he's gonna die a
lot yeah but I mean like it's the
original name of this movie was all you
need is kill me finally yeah that's
that's true yeah just fact I don't know
it's the well he will he like really
like some it's are close cousins yeah
like cuz you know oblivion falls into
some of the same studio
I mean by the same a source kind of
similar no spoiler but yeah there's a
choice to be made in those films yeah
some point as I'm sure a character will
make choices in this film as well um
I'll see it you know what I'll see it
I'll see you with you Jim
it looks really fun it does look fun and
I have to say anytime the decide a big
sci-fi movie goes in the practical route
or races a lot of what they're doing a
prime yeah
I'll see you later that makes me feel a
bit inside also it has to be said let's
say Tom Cruise has had a rough go of it
from a PR standpoint for quite a while
then I have because I made I would argue
against that I think I think all press
is good press if the man makes good
choices yes for movies he says it makes
good movies like look back in his
filmography he makes a lot of very very
solid movies emily Blunt's great doug
liman has a history of making very
competent action movies yeah and still
Paxton and Phil Bill Paxton
I don't know Knox but yeah Jimmy must
see it in KC still it sees bill again I
can say hey guess what I just saw it
tomorrow and you were great in it so my
record remains untarnished so let us
know what you think a veg of tomorrow
and the trailer and as always let us
know what you're looking forward to in
the year of 2014 until next time I'm
Ryan and I'm Jimmy